all right guys
bang bang i've got max here with me dude
thank you so much for doing this
thanks awesome to be here absolutely
let's jump right into your background
uh this is not the first company
finimize that you started uh tell us
kind of where you grew up and
and what that first business was sure so
uh i grew up originally in uh in berlin
and i grew up
in the sector of berlin that was
american that's why i have this weird
german-american slang or
dialect and uh and basically then
studied in the uk
studied in the uk and the u.s economics
and international relations
and never really had a job
i've always been in the startup world uh
with the exception of one year i did
right out of uni or university i did one
year at a consulting firm
for like media sports strategy and uh
what ended up happening is i tried to
uh recruit one of the partners there to
to start a consulting firm
uh with me and do a spin out until i
realized that actually this is this is
kind of boring
um and then i started my first company
and um
that was an e-commerce business and it
was a it was a very random story
um so i ended up in in zurich in
switzerland
out of all places because i had a couple
of friends who studied there and they
were like starting a company
and um we originally started off with a
kind of groupon
daily deal kind of model uh if you
remember those days
and uh and that was kind of the starting
point uh
that allowed us to get like super high
uh growth rates
and build up a user base really quickly
and then one day we kind of looked at
the data and we're like all right like
we've hey we're kind of hit the ceiling
a little bit
in the domestic market and b uh
the sustainability because the with this
whole daily deal model it's all about
like
the retention and the recurring uh
bookings from from merchants
and that was not super easy and i think
you're kind of seeing that all over the
world
so i think the thing that we did pretty
cleverly if i may say so myself
is we kind of transitioned the entire
business into becoming a full-on
e-commerce business and so we ended up
having our own warehouse
we had like 60 people just working in a
warehouse in the end
we took our own inventory and everything
we essentially built a multi-category
e-commerce shop um ended up being the
largest one
uh just amazon was larger in switzerland
and uh we were reaching like 25 of all
households
uh in a small but very very wealthy
country
and then we kind of hit the ceiling
again because you kind of like okay we
have
super high brand recognition more people
knew us than british airways
within the country and so if you haven't
chopped with us at that point in time
then
you probably just didn't care for what
we did and we couldn't really
force it and so then we basically
reached this point where we said okay
you know it's
probably time to to either think about
internationalization or or about
a sale and uh we spoke to a few
um too few potential acquirers and ended
up selling it
um to the largest e-commerce sorry to
the largest media house
switzerland um and this was at the end
of 2015.
um and so that was really my first
startup founder venture building kind of
experience
um and that then led me to start
finimize
um and those are two very very different
companies that i've built
uh ecom the e-commerce business was a
very mercenary business
so our number one goal was how the hell
do we get as much revenue as we possibly
can
um and i think we then sort of
retroactively try to
create like a mission around it but i
think that was one of the learnings and
also
you can't apply a mission in retrospect
and so with finimize it's been the
complete opposite it's been a uh it's
been a personal experience
led me to start the company we have a
really strong mission which i'm happy to
dive into all that but uh
that's kind of the story that got me to
where i am today
absolutely and what was like your one or
two biggest takeaways from building that
company at such a young age
so number one was uh and i think i see
this
across the board with a bunch of younger
founders is
you'd totally underestimate the soft
factor stuff so when you're young and
you're ambitious you're like
you know screw screw like core values
like let's just go
go go go and and then you kind of
realize as you mature and as you start
recruiting people and you start sort of
measuring
what's the health of the culture i think
you start appreciating all these soft
factors a lot more
um and and that's been one of the key
learnings that i've taken away
number one uh so that's been actually
one of the things um
that i the very first thing before i
started cinemas was i wrote
our culture manifest and uh and you can
find it on our website finimize.com
culture it's public and uh
again that during this covert time that
has been absolutely vital
in getting us through this um so that's
number one i think culture and
the importance of soft soft factors
number two i think the importance
of scale and then being able to try out
new things
so like i said back back there in a
fairly small country
we had very large scale and that allowed
us to just try out a bunch of different
verticals so we
we sold you anything from from furniture
to sports to fashion all the way to sex
toys like you whatever you wanted you
could buy with us
and at the same time though we would
start verticals and then we would see
this isn't working and we would shut
them down and
we had that ability to do this
experimentation because
we had that scale and the scale allowed
us to actually get
real signal from the market i think
that's number two and then number three
at the end of the day i think uh
obviously it always comes down to uh
hiring the right people
and and having a good business model but
i think the first two are the key things
that really sort of
gotten and pressed into into my mind i
love that
and what is finimize so how did you
start venomize and what was kind of the
idea for the business
sure so like i said it's been a much
more personal experience
uh i'll i'll quickly tell you what
happened um to give you a bit of context
so
what i did is i was in my mid to late
20s at the time
and everybody's like hey you need to
start saving up some money
you know as you approach 30 all that
stuff and so i did that and
what i did is every month i took money
from my salary and i just put it onto a
savings account
and i did that for a couple of months
and one day i woke up
and i realized fantastic news i've built
up savings
then the immediate follow-up question
was what do i do with those savings
and because i saw you know interest
rates were lower than inflation etc
and so the very first thing that i went
to go do is i went to go see a financial
advisor
and what happened was i walked through
the door
and there was a lovely lady uh very
friendly et cetera but i noticed she'd
already laid out all the brochures onto
the table
and i and i saw that each brochure had
their logo on it
and and i very quickly realized okay
this is going to be a sales pitch for
their products rather than
them genuinely wanting to help me and i
knew straight away that's not the right
solution for me
and so i went back home and i started to
inform myself
as much as i could on investing and
finance and all that stuff
online which frankly wasn't an easy
endeavor and then in the evenings i
would meet friends and i was in a
fortunate position that a lot of them
were working in finance
and i would just bombard them with all
the questions that i had about
the stuff that i'd learned that day and
then at the same time
i kept bumping into people who were in
the same boat as i was so they were
lacking the finance knowledge
but they weren't fortunate enough like i
was that they had that community
of people around them who could help
empower them to make the right investing
decisions
and that was the genesis moment for
finimize um where i started to
dive in a bit deeper and into the whole
topic and realized a couple of things
number one is
i certainly wasn't the only one with
that experience and with that
frustration so 86 of millennials
save each month that they keep more than
half
of their savings in cash just as i was
doing because there isn't a suitable way
to get financial advice
and so that begs the question then why
is that the case and if you dive into
the data and there's been a bunch of
different
research papers on this within the
millennial demographic and you know i'm
a millennial
um 75 percent rough i think 72
say that they want to take direct
control over their wealth
but they lack the know-how to doing so
and so it's all around that missing
know-how piece and then if you look at
the remaining
quarter who do take action 90 of them
say that they consult their friends in
the media before they make a decision
and so it's really with that insight
that we've been building vitimize
and so to answer your question in a very
long-winded kind of way
what we're doing is we're building the
world's most engaged and largest
finance community and there's really two
tenets to that
number one is we want to give our
members access to
best-in-class content from a team of
analysts that we've hired
and number two is we want to give you
access to
your local and now virtual community
so that you can learn from the
experiences of other people who've gone
through exactly that financial journey
that you're about to go to
got it and so let's talk about community
first right that's kind of like the
backbone of what you're trying to build
here
talk a little bit about how you've
thought about building the community
um and then how that kind of plays out
in the products and content that you
guys are
are putting out in the world so
i have to admit that we never really sat
set out to build a community it happened
very organically on the back of our
content
and so what happened was that we
one day so we started off with it with a
with a newsletter product
um and since then have have sort of
launched
other products and mediums as well but
that was like our starting point
and we would explain to people in three
minutes every day
here's the main things that you need to
care about in the world of finance and
most importantly why you should care
about it
so why you should care if interest rates
go up or go down and how that might
affect your person
and then what would happen is uh one day
we're like hey let's go meet these
people who read
our content and we we met in in london
in a pub
and as you do and we were super
surprised that
i think like 50 people showed up and we
very quickly fitmeis took over that pub
and we thought hey this is pretty cool a
we get to meet all these people and b
they get to learn from each other and so
we we did that over and over and over
and these things started getting larger
and larger and larger and so in london
we would have meetups
of like three sometimes even 400 people
showing up
and then we would start getting emails
because we would post it on our social
media or say it in our newsletter
um of people in la saying hey can you do
this in la or like people in sydney
being like can you
sydney and we said we'd love to do this
because
that would be an amazing life to have
and just to fly around the world and
host meetups but we can't
but why don't you do this in sydney and
why don't you do this in l.a
and here's our playbook and and we trust
you with the brand
and we empower you uh to host your own
meetup and
that's really what gave birth to our
sort of meetup community
and now you know last last year we
connected around about 15 000 people
in in the physical world at meetups
literally all over the world there's not
been a single continent where we haven't
been
and there's a meet-up happening pretty
much every single day of the week
somewhere around the world and it's all
completely
voluntary which brings me back to the
mission and this year with virtual we've
completely shifted it to virtual and
we've actually
this year already doubled so we've
connected more than 30 000 people at our
meetups
uh and that's really a driving force uh
for how we think about product
brand etc um i'm happy to dive into that
as well yeah and so when you think of
this how much
of it is i basically have created a
playbook or
infrastructure and i'm going to kind of
arm the community to interact with each
other right like i'm going to give you
the tools i'm going to give you the
playbook
uh and then you guys go and do it versus
you guys are still
maybe not micromanaging but definitely
like hey there should be a meet up
tomorrow in dublin and then the day
after that we're going to do one in
singapore and you guys are kind of
centrally planning
some degree yeah so this is the constant
uh
um sort of swinging along the spectrum
of like
completely giving up control and and and
be having a very very tight-knit
community and and so what we found what
works for us and i think there's
examples for either side of the spectrum
we kind of for us figured out that
sitting somewhere in the middle
works best so um we
are very strict in terms of who can
actually host a meetup
so like in a quarter we'll have a couple
of thousand applications for people
wanting to host a meetup
and we'll take in like maybe 50.
uh so we on that part we're super strict
so that we might make sure that the
brand is represented well because what
happens otherwise is that people attend
these meetups
and it's a [ __ ] experience and it looks
bad on cinemas and so that's obviously
our brand is a huge
asset that we need to maintain but then
you know at the end of the day we say to
them you you know
we have a very engaged community for
example in nigeria
and i have no idea what are the
financial topics in nigeria
and so we depend on them to surface the
topics that are interesting to their
local communities
and they get to pick it and they get to
organize it but we basically provide the
platform
and uh and and the playbook for them
got it and as part of this entire um
process what would you say or the one or
two things that you've learned
that for those that are trying to figure
out how to build community
you know for their business or their
products what are those
things that you're like if i did this
all over again here's the two things
that i would really double down on and
focus on
these are my learnings yeah so
i think the reason for us why this
worked so well and and this is uh
um manifest manifests itself also when
we ask these because
i always have these friends who like
work at top tier banks or like in
private equity
funds and they're like why the hell does
someone host a meetup for you without
getting paid
and puts all this effort into it like
why do they do this like
is this fake or like are you paying them
and i'm like no it's genuinely these
people do this because
they believe in the mission and so the
having this really strong mission and
our mission is we want to empower people
to become their own financial advisors
and that really resonates with our
audience and that's what
what draws people in so i think that's
that's absolutely crucial
um and then i think you know having that
that really balanced approach of
giving control but also having very very
strict guidelines on what can and can't
do can't be done i think those are the
two main areas that are important
got it and then let's talk about how you
guys make money because i think part of
this is like it's great to have
you know uh content which you guys do
and we'll talk about in a minute uh it's
great to have community which you do
but at some point you got to make money
but you guys aren't just making money
you guys are doing very very well
um in kind of the finance vertical
across a number of countries how the
hell do you guys make money
good question um so so we have uh
we're basically building a multi-revenue
stream business
um the first revenue stream is pretty
straightforward
we have an audience that's highly
relevant to a lot of financial brands
and so we do advertising and we let them
advertise
through native advertising in our
primarily
in our newsletter but also our website
then we have a premium subscription or
premium membership
where the end consumer pays so it's
around about 60 dollars a year and then
you get access to our full content
library
and you get access to premium meetups
and a bunch of other things
and then the third piece which is
actually um
fairly nascent for us um
and we never like thought about it until
a bunch of people started approaching us
is we haven't we have an api business as
well
and so what happens is um asset managers
investment platforms etc
they come to us and they say hey we love
your content can we have it
and um now we can say yes
you can have it all you have to do is
you have to plug into our api and you
can
immediately integrate it into your own
user experience
and that gives them access to text and
audio content whatever they want
um in order to then increase the
engagement with their own
user base so those are the three revenue
streams that we are pursuing
got it let's start uh in reverse order
let's start with the api
uh what are they using um the content
for uh
and then how do you think about pricing
that or getting paid
uh via that api and the licensing
sure so we basically offer
today um an out-of-the-box solution
which uh which lets you either get
access to our daily
news and insights or to our weekly news
and insights and then we
we give you that either in text or in
audio
and so the cheapest version that you can
get is weekly text and the most
expensive version that you can get is
daily audio
and so to give you an example without
giving any specific brands so
we had we had a um an investment
platform come to us and they said
we have 10 million users um 2 million of
them are active
we want to activate the remaining 8
million and in order to do that we
believe content is the way to do so
and that was the the pitch point
for them and so that's how that works
it's it's interesting for us also
because obviously a lot of these um apps
and platforms don't have audio and so
they build
media players just to integrate our our
audio content
and then in terms of pricing you know to
be totally honest we're like i said it's
very nascent so we're still
figuring out what's the right price
point for each of them um
and uh currently we're we're
pitching it as a flat fee but then
obviously sort of what's normal for
licensing business
is uh that you start also having uh
usage based
components in there but currently it's
very simple you come to us
you pick what you want and then you and
then you pay an annual license
and then what we're also doing is if you
want to have custom content within that
license and within that api that's also
something that we look at
got it and let's talk about uh
subscriptions and advertising obviously
those two
are uh sometimes at odds with each other
right i think there's just like debate
should you do advertising should you do
subscriptions
everyone thinks it's a binary world you
guys are doing both
so maybe talk through just how you think
about um kind of when to put advertising
somewhere versus when to go subscription
uh and the pros the pros and cons of
that decision
yeah so to be totally honest we actually
started with
uh with subscription and then
kind of moved more into advertising
because we
don't necessarily so we actually
originally thought exactly what you were
saying so we thought
you got to pick one or the other and we
picked subscription um
but i think you know i think the best
example of a company that's proven that
both can work is the new york times
i think they've done a phenomenal job in
building up both and obviously for
subscription for them is something
that's been uh that's
really really been taking off alongside
advertising
the way that we think about it is we
have a free product and it's super high
quality you know we have
we we have analysts um who write all the
content so they're
expensive and we give out that that
piece of content in our newsletter for
free and so we monetize that through
through advertising and for us there's
also a user benefit because we often
find that users use our advertising
specifically with financial brands as a
discovery
product so they find out about new
platforms like oh here's an investment
platform that lets you invest
into art or here's an investment
platform that lets you invest into
sneakers and stuff like that
which they normally perhaps wouldn't
come across and so
in the premium product and i think this
is where we're different to perhaps
a new york times or any of those guys in
the premier product we have zero
advertising
so once you pay it removes all of the
ads
and that's how we that's how we separate
it got it
and when you think about growing the
business from here is this something
where you'll continue to invest in all
three of these uh revenue channels right
so you'll continue to have advertising
uh subscription and also the licensing
business or do you see the business
evolving as you get larger to kind of
coalesce around one of those revenue
streams
um right now the plan is that to
continue with with all three
um so i we
so we have we've built this internal
funnel i guess so obviously our our main
aim
is to upgrade someone into a
subscription
uh and if we fail to do that then we
obviously
still can monetize our users through
advertising and so
we're able to achieve really interesting
unit economics that way
and then like i said the the licensing
business is super interesting
um because it's essentially a pure
contribution margin for us
um but it's very nascent um and so
it's it's hard i would love for it to
work but uh
but it's early days absolutely
let's talk a little bit about new
revenue streams are there other things
that you have looked at that you think
are interesting whether they're
physical products or other types of
things that could potentially become
part of the business
or do you think it's just these three
that you'll stick with
so we have a lot of discussion about
that with uh within our board around
you know i think there's different
businesses who have different strategies
when it comes to revenues uh some people
say
focus on one and and and more revenue
streams you add
the less focus you are and that's bad
for the business and then others
um say the opposite um
i think for now we're just going to
focus on on on those three and if we
were to explore other ones
um i think there's a bunch of things
that we could do you know one thing that
we could do
is go further downstream and actually go
into a transaction
so we know that a lot of our users want
to take a transaction
so that's an avenue that we could take
another one
is uh sort of the more classic media
play which is
go into merchandise uh
that could be that could be is probably
a smaller one but kind of a fun one to
do
um but to be honest right now uh we
don't want to like spread it
any more thinly um one thing that we
that we do occasionally do
is uh research uh so obviously we have a
lot of access to people and their
uh investing behaviors and attitudes
that's something that we might
explore a little bit further but again
we don't want to get
too distracted with uh by spreading
ourselves within
absolutely and when you think about kind
of the
team how does your team change based on
these various
monetization strategies do you have to
go and uh kind of hire a completely new
team with new skill set or do you
continue just to
kind of use the team that you have maybe
add some people but uh you learn the
skill
as you guys go into the new monetization
strategy
no so we're we're very lean um and
uh we we like that and we like being
lean
um and so we we have one content team
that content team
produces free and that same content
team produces premium same with the
licensing
um and and i i think that's the way it
has to be because that's the only way
that you can ensure consistency
across all the different products um
and for us really it's all about the
quality of the people who we hire
who produce the content that's the
number one thing it doesn't really
matter
what product they end up working on got
it
what is the thing that you're most
excited about moving forward given the
audience you have
in finance i know that uh obviously kind
of the robin hood trader has become
the topic du jour of a lot of the
mainstream media
but how do you think about the pandemic
impacting that audience that kind of
rise of the millennial investor or the
robin hood investor and how that will
impact the business in the future
yeah so what so i think what's
interesting and i know that you're
big into uh crypto um so in 2018
um we saw a really interesting surge in
people actually being interested
in finance in general and i think crypto
was a big driver there
right um then now we're seeing a big
surge again and people being interested
uh through this whole robin hood surge
um
and so i think what you're seeing is
these these drivers or these triggers
that lead people to
to enter the world of finance which
perhaps typically would have been
something that would have been a bit too
mystic and a bit too dull for them and
and these triggers allow them to sort of
peek into that world
um our our the way that we are always
have position ourselves is we are not
for the day trader
we are for people who want to have a
sophisticated more refined more
thoughtful
trading strategy or investing strategy
and the way that we describe our
persona of a customer is the casual
investor
and i think you're starting to get many
many more casual investors
as a result of all the things that are
happening um
and what a casual investor is someone
who
wants to actively invest because they
don't just want to be passive
completely passive they might be
partially passive but they also don't
want to be
a day trader and so these are the kind
of people who might spend a couple of
hours a week on investing not every
single day
and that's really who we are catering
the product got it
one of the things that you said
previously is like the importance of
copywriting so the way that you
communicate with
your customer or your audience talk a
little bit about what you mean
uh why that is such an important skill
set
yeah so i think copywriting is one of
the most overlooked skill sets
that you can have and people really just
take it for granted and
i think for us sort of taking a step
back the
sort of secret sauce that we have or
that we like to think we have is
we managed to synthesize two things that
are typically not synthesized very
easily or very well
on the one side is we we take substance
so that's why we hire
ex-analysts who really really know what
they're talking about
and on the other side we have simplicity
and that's why we hire copywriters and
so typically what you have is you have
people with substance who produce these
really complicated convoluted reports
that nobody really understands and on
the other side you have people who
produce
pretty shallow but very easy to
understand
financial content but it's so shallow
that it actually doesn't really add any
value to you
and so what we really focus on is
combining those two things um
and so copy i think for us is the
crucial piece that grabs someone's
attention
and the way that we think about that is
and we've always been picturing this
user is
imagine someone standing at the subway
station it's loud
they have their their headphones plugged
in they're reading what you're what
you've been writing
and they probably have 50 of their
attention span
is with you and as soon as they have to
re-read a sentence
we've lost them and so we need to be
able to write in a way
that a conveys the substance but b has a
nice flow is conversational et cetera
and i think that's one of those things
that's way easier said than done
and is a real craft um and you see that
both
on the actual content side but also you
know more recently we started doing paid
acquisition for the first time really
and that's a big big driver at the end
of the day paid acquisition is all about
how good is your copy and your ad credit
and so hugely important skill set have
you seen an
impact on the cost of acquisition uh by
simply changing the ad copy but kind of
same target same audience uh same
platform i mean i'm a firm believer that
the the people who win and paid
acquisition are the people who win with
ad creators
i mean that's also the way that we've
been structuring our own organization
is as much testing as you can do
with ad creatives and typically what we
find is
the copy in our experience the copy is
more important even than the visual
uh so again copy is everything
absolutely
makes uh makes a lot of sense um you've
hired
tons of analysts but not journalists
explain that decision
yeah so um like i said we really really
focus on
on the substance part uh and you know
when we
started with our newsletter product uh
we've always been answering three
questions for our users number one is
what's going on here number two is what
does this mean and number three
why should you care and the why should
you care
question what we found is not something
that a financial journalist
and and i don't mean to offend anybody
out there but in our experience it's not
something that they are able to
answer very well because they don't have
that deep understanding that someone
from the industry has
and so when we did the hiring you know
we um
we interviewed a range of candidates
from the with journalism background
because that's kind of the obvious
that profile that you want to hire for
someone and we just figured
or we just found that the quality of the
insights that they provide
just isn't strong enough and so that's
then what what you know
ended up leading us to the analysts and
so we've hired people
um you know we more most recent hire
someone who was at goldman sachs for 10
years
and uh we only hire analysts right now
we have one exception
and and he kind of sits at the
intersection of uh
product and content and he um was a
managing editor at bloomberg for 10
years
um so he's the one exception that we've
made but other than that we've always
hired analysts because
the insights that they provide is what
we're really looking after
absolutely do you think that other media
companies could benefit from kind of
taking a similar strategy of almost
hiring people who are either one have
skin in the game so actually the
investors themselves
uh or the kind of analysts who have
spent years and years
kind of more focused on analysis rather
than just journalism
i i mean i think it really depends on
what what the publication wants to do
um our so when we define internally what
we care about
is we care all about providing insights
and so in order to provide insights you
need people to understand it and that's
what led us there
if if your thing is hey i just want to
have breaking news and i want to be the
first one to break that
i don't think you necessarily need that
you probably actually or if you want to
have investigative pieces you probably
want to have a journalist because that's
their skill set
but i think as soon as you start really
digging into something and
and providing those insights i think it
makes a lot of sense
absolutely what's the biggest challenge
for you guys moving forward
good question um we always have a bunch
of challenges that we're thinking about
um i think for us it's uh
it's all about um when we think about
what we're doing is we we
essentially are creating a new kind of
product category um
a a product where people are paying to
get financial insights
there isn't really a product out there
that exists yet
um similar to what maybe like a
headspace and a calm did in the
meditation space you know getting people
into this space where they're paying for
meditation
was something new was was category
defining and we believe
that we are doing something similar in
the financial news analysis insights
space so the challenge that that brings
is
you're constantly having to educate the
market on what you're doing
why this is worth paying for why you
can't google this
and so i think it's all about customer
and market
education and development that's really
what we're focusing on
got it and then for you personally like
we talked a little bit about what you've
learned in your first company what have
you learned in this company so far
that other founders could uh could
benefit from hearing
i think i applied the thing that i
learned from my previous company
with the culture manifest and defining
that early on
i think that's been an absolute winner
um and i would definitely do that again
um so really focusing on getting the
soft factors and the soft values right
i think importance of brand um again
is something that's super crucial and
that's something that you just
build up every single day by providing
value to your end users
um and then i think uh monetization
so when we started out um we had a very
different business plan
in place and i would probably next time
um i try i guess try to put a little bit
more emphasis on
the business plan from day one rather
than building
great product that you're proud of and
building a good brand because you need
both
and i think we kind of did a lot of
experimentation and figured it out along
the way
um which maybe that's the natural way to
do it and i know a lot of companies have
done it but
uh it's probably easier if you if you
really nail it from day one
got it before i wrap up i always ask
everyone the same two questions and then
you'll get a chance to ask me one
the first is what's the most important
book that you've ever read
that's a good question um the most
important i mean i guess
i guess i'll i'll give you two answers
one is uh
sort of on the on the business side um i
love reading business books
uh so i love stuff like shoe dog
um and i love stuff like um
i just read michael orbitz's
autobiography which was which was
super entertaining and really
interesting
but i think in terms of the book that i
really love uh because i think it's a
it's a really interesting perspective on
life
it's uh the little prince um from santa
experience
um i don't know if you've ever heard of
it but it happened why that one
it's a uh it's i guess it's uh
it's a so it's a french book from uh
from a french author
uh the little prince it's a very simple
book it's it's sort of intended to be
for children um but
it's an adult book with really really
important
life lessons if you sort of uncover it a
little bit and go a little bit below the
surface
and it just you know gives you lessons
and perspectives on
you know what matters in life uh what
matters with relationships what matters
with love
all the stuff that i think in our world
of business and finance you kind of
lose and i think that book does is just
a really refreshing read
to sort of open your mind again i love
that answer
second question is more fun aliens are
you a believer or a non-believer
i'm not a i'm not a believer today but
i'm open
to being convinced so i'm not
categorically against it
why not a believer yet i guess
i haven't really seen any any uh
indication of it
um i know that there's you know that you
always read these studies that are
coming out
um from different planets but i don't
know i probably
believe in ghosts more than i believe in
aliens
uh but yeah why wouldn't you think ghost
you're like the third you're like the
third person ever to say that why do you
believe in
ghosts uh i don't think i believe in
ghosts per se but
i think i probably believe in ghosts a
little bit more than i believe in aliens
just because sometimes
things happen and you're there isn't
really a good explanation for it and
you're kind of
in this um old historic place or
something like that and you're like oh i
guess it could have been a ghost
i love it what's the one question you
got for me to uh to wrap us up
uh i actually have a quick one okay one
is
so so my favorite part of your podcast
is when you open up and you say bang
bang
what's the what's the background there
uh literally there is none i just did it
one day and then i was like
i'm gonna do it again and then uh about
the third time
uh i was like well i probably can't stop
now like in
a couple hundred episodes later like
just bang bang what's up
i love that it's uh it sets the energy
tone right
and then the second question is so
bitcoin
on a rise where do you think it's going
to go this time
i think we see 100k by the end of next
year for sure
really into 2021. um
you know how much higher than that
i have no clue could it not go to 100
absolutely
like i kind of just think of it as
[Music]
the the thesis is there like there's a
fixed supply demand's only going to
continue to increase over time
uh how long does that take what are the
price targets all that is debatable
but like you know it's going to be worth
more
you know 10 years from now than it is
today type thing right
and you think uh last time we hit this
sort of 18k
mark then afterwards it all started
dripping down again
you're convinced uh or you're bullish
it's not gonna happen this time
oh no i i think that we get another kind
of parabolic run
let's say you know i don't know say 100k
right or whatever the number ends up
being
um and then from there you get a pretty
nasty
like 80 drawdown again um so i kind of
you know if you put a gun to my head and
said uh what do i think is going to
happen
100k or more by the end of next year uh
and then after that kind of blow off top
you'll then get a pretty nasty drawdown
um you know 80 probably some somewhere
in that range
uh then you'll go through a multi-year
kind of bear market like we did
uh already and then you'll basically um
you know kind of get another parabolic
run again so it's uh
you know over the last 11 years this
game has been played right
and it's kind of done this a number of
times i tend to think that uh you know
this is no different we're just in the
next cycle of it
yeah awesome so we'll we'll see
uh max thank you so much for doing this
where can we send people to find you on
the internet or find out more about
finimize
sure so uh you can find me personally on
twitter
i have a bizarre twitter handle which is
whole earth
web uh which is a whole story to it but
whole earth
you're gonna have to tell us what the
story is um
so i was uh when i really got in so i
was like one of those kids in
in in school i was like the first kid in
my high school to have a website so i've
always been
really into the web and i kind of went
down this
really sort of rabbit hole for a year or
something
uh understanding where the world wide
web came from
and i and i found out about the whole
earth catalog
from stuart brand and i bought one and
everything and i looked at that and then
i was like oh
i guess you know those guys who were the
hippies of that generation
they actually helped create the world
wide web so
i thought i was going to be smart and
just combine the terms whole earth
catalog with web
which led me to whole earth web uh and
now i have to stick with it
and you've been using that as uh as kind
of
the uh the name on the internet since
yeah you know i kind of stuck i i one
day i signed up for twitter and like
ever since i've been having it i kind of
like it it's not
great for like personal recognition but
i'll stick with it i love it
all right so they can find you there on
on twitter and then what about
for minimize uh you can find us on on
twitter just finimize you can
go to our website finimize.com
f-i-n-i-m-i-z-e
instagram social media et cetera and in
all the app stores
so uh apple and android
i love it man you are uh you're a legend
i appreciate you uh taking the time to
do this
and uh obviously you've built a very
very large engaged audience
uh and community uh and are figuring out
how to kind of in a win-win way monetize
it so thank you so much for coming on
and we'll definitely have to do this
again in the future
thank you awesome